Publisher Shueisha is celebrating the series' 50th anniversary.
The exhibit spans three eras,...
...this one focusing on the 1970s to 1980s when both KK and I were kids.
You can see he has a lot of passion for those childhood memories,...
...reading every copy of Shonen Jump as a kid,...
The walls are lined with scenes from the weekly manga.
Each issue has 20 serial series, each with 20 pages per week.
Popular serial series can go on for decades...
...like KK's favorite KochiKame, which continued for 40 years.
Action and humor is the name of the game on the pages of Jump.
Captain Tsubasa, started in 1981 and still running today,...
...has published over 70 million copies to date.
The story revolves around an eleven-year-old elementary school kid...
...who wants to win the FIFA World Cup for Japan.
This scene was recreated on playgrounds, everywhere.